>>> GEORGIA VOTERS BEING ASK
TO MAKE THEIR VOICES HEARD, YES,
AGAIN.
STATEWIDE EARLY VOTING FOR T
SENATE RUNOFF ARTED TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK, THIS IS CROWDS
LINING UP BRIGHT AND EARLY THIS
MORNING IN ATLANTA.
IT'S NOT JIM SCIUTTO TODAY, WE
SAW SIMILAR SCENES THROUGHOUT
THE WEEKEND, SOME TWO DOZEN
COUNTIES WERE ALLOWED TO GET A
HEAD START ON THE EARLY RUNOFF
VOTING.
THE CANDIDATES WILL HAVE A BUSY
FINAL WEEK ON THE STUMP.
RAFAEL WARNOCK AND HERSCHEL
WALKER BEGINNING THAT FINAL WEEK
WITH RALLIES WITH THEIR
SUPPORTERS TODAY.
GREAT REPORTERS BACK AT THE
TABLE WITH US.
VOTING IS LIKE I HAVE TO FILL UP
MY TANK, I HAVE TO GO TO
STARBUCKS AND I HAVE TO VOTE.
IT MUST SEEM LIKE A DAILY
ROUTINE BUT THIS RACE IS
IMPORTANT.
>> YES, WITH, YOU KNOW, THE
RUNOFF SYSTEM IN PLACE BOTH NOR
PRIMARIES AND GENERAL ELECTIONS
AND RUNOFFS, YOU KNOW, GEORGIA
HAS TO GO TO THE POLL A LOT, BUT
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS THAT VOTERS
ARE ENERGIZED.
VOTERS ARE SHOWING UP WHEN THEY
HAD THAT FLEXIBILITY THIS
WEEKEND, THEY TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
IT.
THERE IS VERY ROBUST TURNOUT,
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS YET ANOTHER
ELECTION FOR GEORGIA, IT'S BEEN
ALMOST CONTINUOUS FOR THE PAST
TWO YEARS.
>> THE SPENDING IS OFF THE
CHARTS, I WILL SHOW YOU THE
NUMBER.
$27.4 MILLION FOR DEMOCRATIC
SPENDING JUST FROM THE GENERAL
ELECTION, THIS IS JUST THE
RUNOFF.
YOU SEE THE DATES NOVEMBER 9th
THROUGH -- REPUBLICANS, THOUGH,
REPUBLICANS HAVE GOOSED UP THEIR
SPENDING IN THE LAST SEVERAL
DAYS, WHEN WE HAD THOSE NUMBERS
LAST WEEK THEY WERE BEHIND.
YOU SEE THE REPUBLICANS DECIDED
WE NEED THIS SEAT.
WE WANT THIS SEAT.
>> THEY NEED AND WANT.
IT'S NOT DETERMINATIVE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE BALANCE OF POWER,
WE KNOW THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE THAT
LOCKED UP, BUT EVERY SINGLE
VOTE, EVERY SINGLE SEAT MATTERS.
WE'VE SEEN THAT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN.
THE IDEA OF THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
AN OUTRIGHT MAJORITY 51 VOTES AS
OPPOSED TO 5050 WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT BREAKING THE TIE IS
REALLY KEY.
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY IS REALLY
STAGGERING.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THE NUMBERS
YOU JUST PUT UP, BUT THAT'S JUST
IN THE RUNOFF AND IT'S NOT JUST
THE MONEY OF COURSE, I THINK ONE
OF THE KEYS, I THINK YOU'VE BEEN
REPORTING ON, IS GOVERNOR KEMP.
THE FACT THAT KEMP HAS TURNED ON
HIS MACHINE, THE ONE THAT HELPED
GET HIM ELECTED, HE IS A VERY
DIFFERENT PERSON, A VERY
DIFFERENT CANDIDATE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FIELD OPERATIONS.
>> AND AXIOS REPORTING TODAY
THAT HE'S SETTING UP A FEDERAL
PAC AT WELL.
HE COULD USE IT TO SUPPORT -- HE
WOULD HAVE TO DO IT QUICKLY TO
GET HELP IN HERE FOR HERSCHEL
WALKER.
IT'S CLEAR JUST THAT FACT THAT
KEMP IS RAISING HIS NATIONAL
PROFILE NOW.
HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WITH
WALKER IN THE NORMAL ELECTION
PERIOD AND NOW HE IS TRYING TO
HELP HERSCHEL WALKER SO NOBODY
CAN SAY AFTER THE FACT YOU ARE
NO BLAME.
>> EXACTLY.
ALL EYES OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
ARE ON THIS SO HE WANTS TO BE A
LEADER IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
HE IS SOMEONE REALLY A VERY RARE
SPECIES, ACTUALLY, IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHO NAVIGATED
THE FIERCE OPPOSITION FROM THE
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
AND HE DID JUST FINE.
HE DIDN'T SPEAK OUT AGAINST HIM
NECESSARILY BUT DIDN'T BUCKLE OR
BACK DOWN TO HIM DURING THE 2020
ELECTION, BUT AS DANA WAS
SAYING, THE MAJORITY IS SET, BUT
HAVING THAT -- THE EXTRA VOTE,
YES, IT GIVES YOU SOME BREATHING
ROOM WITH JOE MANCHIN BUT THIS
IS WHY IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE OF COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS
AND THE MAKEUP OF COMMITTEES,
THAT MEANS THERE WILL NOT BE AN
EVEN SPLIT ON ALL OF THE
COMMITTEES, DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE
A TRUE MAJORITY.
EVERY STAFFER UP ON CAPITOL HILL
RIGHT NOW IS REALLY WATCHING
THIS BECAUSE IT MAKES A HUGE
DIFFERENCE FOR INVESTIGATIONS,
FOR SUBPOENAS, BUT ALSO JUST THE
MAKEUP OF THE COMMITTEES.
SO THAT'S WHY DEMOCRATS ARE
FIGHTING JUST AS HARD FOR THIS
AS THOUGH THE SENATE MAJORITY --
>> IF YOU HAVE A MORE AGGRESSIVE
HOUSE INVESTIGATION WHICH WE
WILL GET TO LATER AND IN THE
WEEKS AHEAD, HAVING SUBPOENA
POWER IN THE SENATE ALLOWS YOU
TO COUNTERPROGRAMMING TO BE
PREPARED TO DO THAT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE EYE POPPING
SPENDING, EVERY VOTE COUNTS IN
GEORGIA, BUT LIKE IN MANY STATES
THE ASIAN AMERICAN POPULATION IS
A GROWING AND SWING
CONSTITUENCY.
THIS IS THE SAME WARNOCK AD
RUNNING WITH CHINESE, VIETNAMESE
AND KOREAN SUBTITLES.
>> VOTING IN A REAL SENSE IS A
KIND OF PRAYER FOR THE KIND OF
WORLD THAT WE WANT TO SEE AND
OUR PRAYERS ARE STRONGER WHEN WE
PRAY TOGETHER.
IT IS THE LORD'S WORK.
>> A MINISTER, OBVIOUSLY,
SENATOR WARNOCK HAS HIS ROOTS
ARE IN THE MINISTRY, BUT THIS IS
A FASCINATING TO ME -- PART OF A
FASCINATING COMPETITION NOT ONLY
IN THE STATE OF GEORGIA, THIS IS
THE NEXT 10, 15, 20 YEARS OF
AMERICAN LIFE AS THE ASIAN
AMERICAN POPULATION IS A SWING
AND SUBURBAN CONSTITUENCY IN
MANY OF THE BATTLE GROUND
STATES.
>> YES, IN GEORGIA BOTH PARTIES
HAVE BEEN COMPETING FOR THE AAPI
VOTE, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
OPENED ONE OF ITS COMMUNITY
CENTERS IN A LARGELY ASIAN PART
OF METRO ATLANTA, THEY'VE ALSO
HAD A COMMUNITY CENTER IN A
BLACK PART OF METRO ATLANTA, BUT
WE KNOW THAT GENERALLY AAPI
VOTERS TEND TO SUPPORT
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES AND IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE WARNOCK CAMPAIGN
IS AWARE OF THAT AS THEY TRY TO
DRUM UP TURNOUT THEY CAR THE
AAPI COMMUNITY PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC BASE THAT THEY NEED
TO SHOW UP, THEY NEED TO TURNOUT
IN HOPES OF WINNING THIS
ELECTION.